puis-je poursuit maintenant avec le
ministre de l'éducation jean françois
roberge qu'on trouve immédiatement
bonjour monsieur roberge bonjour munro
les mesures l'auberge mais poursuivons
justement sur le thème de l'aération
comment ça se fait finalement qu'on
n'aurait pas atteint tous les lecteurs
de co2 pour la rentrée scolaire parce
que c'est un sujet dont nous parlait
pendant toute la dernière année
on n'avait pas dit qu'on installerait
pour le 18 septembre on s'était dit
qu'en septembre on allait déployer les
lecteurs de co2 et s'ils seront offerts
on allait déployer pendant l'automne
d'abord et avant tout dans les classes
ou si notre relation naturelle par
l'ouverture des fenêtres puis ensuite
dans les écoles qui ont des systèmes de
ventilation mécanique
les gens se sont inquiétés de peut-être
de la qualité de l'air on a fait des
tests l'an passé qui ont été somme toute
assez rassurant avec plus de 90% des
classes avaient moins de mille 500 ppm
de co2 c'est un peu technique mais les
experts nous disent que à moins de mille
500 ppm la ventilation est correct il y
avait des preuves des classes plus
problématique et on s'en est occupé il
ya beaucoup de travaux qui ont été faits
par cours de l'été les travaux qui sont
encore aujourd'hui comment se faire
encore demain pour être fin prêt pour la
rentrée des classes est ce que les
parents vont avoir le portrait de leur
école de l'état de la ventilation pour
la rentrée
éventuellement on pourra avoir les
résultats des lecteurs de co2 fraudes
relève déployer les installer l'objectif
c'est d'être capable d'agir s'il ya des
problèmes mais évidemment on a déjà
testé la qualité de l'air on cite dans
la grande grande partie la grande
majorité des classes qui ont aucun
projet n'a d'autre qu'on est capable de
faire les ajustements et c'est déjà fait
donc si on est en fin de parcours ici
l'on n'est pas en train de commencer des
initiations
à moi je comprends pas ce que vous me
dites que pour vous c'est un peu d'eau
si régler la ventilation d'aération
c'est pas tout à fait réglé en cash des
travaux qui se font encore moment où je
vous parle pendant l'été et le
déploiement des lecteurs de co2 mais ça
va se faire d'ici la mi-décembre environ
après ça va comprendre les lectures puis
en premier c'est justement ce on doit le
faire à des classes là de manière
exceptionnelle mais moi aujourd'hui je
me concentre sur le plan de la rentrée
scolaire le fait que oui les jeunes bon
bout porter des masques dans les aires
communes mais prend les enlever en
classe le respect des recommandations de
la santé publique justement alors je
pense vraiment des questions que les
parents se posent le plan c koi s'il ya
un code dans une classe par exemple à ce
que toute la classe se retrouvent à la
maison qui ont fait l'école à distance
comment vous voyez ça ce que je dis
qu'en jalbert aujourd'hui de la santé
publique qui était présent lors du point
de presse c'est qu'on ne pourra pas
copier coller les mesures de l'an passé
à cette année l'arrivée de la
vaccination dans les familles pour les
paroles mais aussi pour nos adolescents
il c'était un beau succès la campagne de
vaccination vont nous permettre d'avoir
des mesures qui sont différents comme
disait monsieur gilbert ils seront moins
agressifs les champs de la santé
publique quand ce sera le temps de
décider de quelle mesure on doit faire
est ce qu'on doit isoler vraiment autant
d'élèves on attend les réponses passent
une question que j'ai posée que demain
on attend des réponses plus détaillées
dans les prochains jours sur les
protocoles à mettre en place car dès que
possible dans les classes mais on ne
revivra pas l'an prochain ce qu'on a
vécu l'an passé dont les parents avaient
hausse en mai l'an dernier un tableau
assez complexe on va se dire l'enjeu le
montre l écran mais c'est vraiment tout
le processus si votre enfant un
septembre plus qu'un symptôme vous
garder à la maison vous fait tester vous
surveiller 24 heures est ce que ça tient
toujours où est ce que les règles
changent à ce niveau là
il y aura de nouvelles infographie le
nouvel
nouvelle aide mémoire qui se renvoyaient
aux parents effectivement ce sera
simplifiée on a pris beaucoup de la
dernière annie jeudi on nous comme
gouvernement mais aussi surtout la
médecine la science a appris beaucoup
donc on aura sans doute une démarche
plus simplifié pour les parrains faut
demeurer vigilant il faut demeurer
prudent c'est pas un retour à la normale
comme si de rien n'était mais ont pu
s'approcher quand même un peu plus d'une
vie normale en ayant la fin des bulles
classe en permettant aux élèves de ces
classes à l'érection finalement c'est
vraiment on va les regarder les
tableaux pour les montrer
un aux téléspectateurs donc on est rendu
pour la première danse jusqu'à 82%
deuxième dose est encore bas on est à 48
% mais si on ajoute les gens qui ont
déjà pris un rendez-vous pour leurs
jeunes ça grimpe à ce moment là jusqu'à
77% est-ce que c'est satisfaisant pour
vous
82% à 2 48 deuxième dose
je pense que c'est très très bien mais
on fait un blitz dans les prochaines
semaines donc on attendra même pas la
rentrée scolaire d'avant d'accentuer les
campagnes de vaccination pour nos
adolescents et dans les quartiers où ça
a répondu un peu moins bien je sais que
la santé publique va organiser dans les
prochains jours des campagnes de
vaccination ciblée avant même la rentrée
scolaire ici une chose est certaine
c'est qu'on va travailler notre
opération gp l'opération collaboration
dès la rentrée scolaire on va aussi
organiser des campagnes de vaccination
dans les milieux scolaires ou avec le
concours des milieux scolaires parfois
on prend l'autobus pour se rendre au
centre de vaccination donc en septembre
un peu comme ce qu'on a fait en juin à
grimper encore plus le taux de
vaccination donc la protection de nos
jeunes mais les élèves auront pas tous
les mêmes avantages en ceux qui n'ont
pas été vaccinés avec les deux doses
vont avoir des limites là vous appliquez
un passeport vaccinale finalement sur
certaines activités
sont des activités parascolaires ou
sportives au risque donc donc exactement
comme ce qui se passe pour les adultes
et bien il y aura l'application d'un
passeport vaccinale pour participer à
des sports qui seront jugées par la
santé publique comme plus susceptibles
de favoriser la propagation donc dans le
doute shahzad l'esa vous qui vous voulez
faire du sport et du parascolaire et
chats faites vous vacciner c'est pas
déjà le cas comme ça mais vous serez
certain de faire vos activités c'est
votre argument de vente
c'est ma vie vous êtes en train
d'utiliser en ce moment
c'est sûr que c'est un incitatif pour
les gens qui sont pas encore
correctement vaccinés de le faire mais
c'est aussi il faudrait une
recommandation de la santé publique
pourraient peut être une mesure de je
dirais de protection pour être capable
de permettre à nos jeunes de faire leur
activité vous savez aval à l'an passé
c'était soit on les offres sont les
autres folle parce que là ça serait
terrible de pénaliser tous les gens
parce que certaines ne sont pas vaccinés
sur la berge merci beaucoup pour
l'entrevue bonne rentrée merci oui au
revoir